so the way it's explained to me is that
the dog sniffs just above the water as
the boat slowly travels through the lake
and that the dog can detect bubbles from
gases given off by a body down below and
the dog will alert on those those smells
they've been using the dog yesterday am
today and I'm not aware of the dog
getting on anything yet I don't know if
the dogs do alert they would they would
record the GPS coordinates of that
location and then they would put forth
dive team with either an ROV or a diver
to go in and check that but there were
no canine hits or alerts that were aware
of any other questions yes so the ROV is
being utilized by the Tulare County
Sheriff's Office they have a crew out
there on a boat so they're using this
the sonar systems to scan the bottom of
the lake and then if they identify any
objects they'll put the ROV down to get
eyes on so to speak of that object and
unfortunately the targets that they've
marked so far and gone down and
investigated have not been what we're
looking for so the search continues I
don't have a statement from the family
our investigators have been with contact
with in contact with the family since
the beginning of this we have a liaison
with the family working with them and of
course they're going through an
extremely difficult time and we're
trying to do everything we can to
provide as much resources and can and
provide some closure for them
I don't know that there's a reason to do
that he was interviewed quite
extensively on the night of that
afternoon so our investigators completed
that task right from the get-go and
that's part of what focused our
resources in specific areas of the lake
it was based on where the boat was found
where it likely came from based on the
wind patterns and things like that and
the statement provided by the trial
we've also interviewed other folks who
were on the lake at the time in boats
and they've provided some clarity as to
where her boat may have been at specific
times so that's been very helpful as
well any new information on what what
items were on a boat I don't my
understanding as long as this operation
is going on the lake will remain closed
to the public it's hard to say like I
said we can't predict I mean we may find
her in an hour from now or several days
from now so there's just no way to
predict that okay yeah so with this
being a reservoir there's trees down
below this is a canyon that essentially
they put a dam on and then flooded many
years ago so it's not like a naturally
occurring lake like in a ball that just
has sediment and rocks on the bottom you
have a creek that runs into it that
connects to lake pyramid north of here
and then you have a creek that runs out
of it and goes to the Santa Clara River
so there is a flow to this lake every
Lake has a certain current and then in
the afternoons you see how the wind
built up comes up the canyon so it
pushes the surface water toward the back
of the canyon even though the flow of
the creek is coming into the lake so
that creates a little bit of an effect
there
but I'm told by some of the divers that
even with that current wherever she went
down they're confident that that's where
she will be found it's just finding that
spot that's the difficult part I mean
you can see the legs more than two miles
long at its deepest point it's about a
hundred and thirty feet deep there's a
lot of area to cover so my understanding
and this was already something that was
planned
I believe it's next month they're gonna
bring the lake level down significantly
I'm told 265 feet because they have to
do some seismic retrofitting on the dam
itself so that was something that was
already planned well in advance not
related to this incident you know what
you'll have to talk to United Water
about that this is their lake and their
water and I'm sure they have a precise
plan on how that's gonna happen any
other questions
sure my first name is Eric could spell
er I see last name is bozo that spelled
bu s CH o W captain Ventura County
Sheriff's Office okay thank you
you